welcome Academy members sag-aftra
members visual effects professionals and
Industry breasts
I am CCH pounder and actor and I am John
Nelson a visual effects supervisor
together we are the co host for
tonight's presentation on acting and
performance capture this technique
enables actors to inhabit new characters
and tell stories never thought possible
before tonight we will show some of the
latest examples of acting and
performance capture great performances
reach you emotionally and to talk about
performance from an actress perspective
our co-host
CCH thank you well there's so much to
talk to him out tonight I just want to
get directly to the point here's the
deal I started off in the theater no
microphone developing your chest cavity
so that your voice could reach the last
seat in the house it was enhanced by
stage props costume stage manager and
these were all the things that helped us
tell the story and then we moved to film
and television suddenly learning to
become small but in fact much bigger
internally assisted by camera
microphones long shots close-ups and
these technical marvels helped us to
tell the story and then by chance I
happen to get a job in Avatar I am to be
nine feet tall blue with a tail and I'm
not voice acting it is me tonight
that magic is going to be explained to
you by John Nelson and all the marvelous
technic
supervises brilliant IT geek guys
tonight here we go I'm here to speak
about performance capture from the
visual effects side but before I start I
just want to have a shout out to Michael
tronic and Jody Gennaro for that that
really awesome open reel it rocked the
house thank you guys so performance and
Technology have always been intertwined
in the movies especially in visual
effects for Max Fleischer his invention
of the rotoscope over a hundred years
ago which brought us Snow White and -
the beautifully tracked cgi of ex
machina we have always wanted to extend
performance with the creative use of
technology this was seen in the
photographic motion studies of Eadweard
Muybridge which evolved through the
computer revolution to become computer
tracking and human motion capture this
combined with CGI characters created
digital doubles which you might remember
for seeing in a Titanic where those
those people jumping into the water in
the background were really motion
captured stunt doubles as the technology
evolved to capture not only the body but
to capture the face motion capture
became performance capture with
professional actors driving the
performance of photorealistic CGI
rendered avatars films like Avatar Lord
of the Rings Pirates of the Caribbean
King Kong Benjamin Button war for the
Planet of the Apes and Blade Runner 2049
have taken these digital characters to
new places sometimes the effect is very
subtle like returning an actor back to a
young age to deliver performance
sometimes it's inhabiting a character
from another planet who might be 10 feet
tall sometimes it's helping an animal
give an intuitive performance only
through verbal grunts facial cues and
body language as for box office appeal
14 of the 20 highest-grossing films
worldwide have employed characters such
as these it all starts with the
performance and then is refined
creatively through visual effects and
animation now let's hear from some of
the actors directors and produce
who have created such characters in
performances